community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
finley acura the sponsors of this next
segment want to remind you there is a
shortage of new car inventory across the
nation they want to make your car
shopping and selling experience
hassle-free during this unique time
[Music]
my name's travis aguilar one of the
sales managers here at findlay acura one
of the valley's best kept secrets we
want to talk to you today about what's
going on in the market nationwide across
every
manufacturer there is a shortage of new
car inventory
luckily with acura we've been able to
receive inventory regularly to where we
are able to help our customers with all
of their vehicle needs
and unlike a lot of our competitors
we're not doing things like price
gouging or charging over the
manufacturer's suggested retail price
so our inventory has been flying we're
doing a lot of pre-orders and stuff like
that in regards to new cars just because
you know we're able to um stand out
amongst our competition with you know
keeping things fair and we want to make
sure we're taking care of our customers
through these unprecedented times
when it comes to
selling your vehicle if you are looking
to sell your vehicle there's a great
need for that so we're very interested
in
taking a look at your vehicle and giving
you maybe a second opinion or giving you
an a professional appraisal and an offer
for
your vehicle many times we've been able
to give several hundred dollars or even
a thousand dollars over
kelly blue book value so we're very
motivated to purchase your vehicle from
you or earn your business and show you
what we're all about here at findlay
acura so if you are in the market for a
vehicle you know a couple things to look
out for is
what vehicles are available in stock our
inventory is turning at an incredible
rate
so you know you can always check out our
website
finleyacura.com or call in
luckily we're connected with the findlay
automotive group so we're not just
you know stuck with the inventory we
have on site we can pull from a
huge network of other dealers and find
the right vehicle for you and like i
said give you a second opinion on your
offer that you may have gotten elsewhere
as well if you're looking to trade in or
just simply sell your vehicle without
purchasing one from us so as you're
shopping you'll notice a lot of lots are
a lot emptier than what they normally
are and that is due to
the shortage of microchips there are a
lot of chips that go into each
individual vehicle in their production
so as
we're sorting that out
inventory has been at an all-time low
nationwide for every manufacturer
but here at findlay acura we do have
vehicles coming in on a weekly basis and
again we're not going to
be price gouging or you know we want to
make sure we're taking care of our
customers and you know we believe that
in the future these are the things that
they're going to remember who treated
them right and that's what leads to
you know our great reputation online and
in the community